We are on problem number 12.
Problem 12.
OK, what is the greatest of five
consecutive integers if
the sum of these integers
is 185?
So what is the greatest?
Let's assume x is the greatest.
And they're
consecutive integers, so what's
the second greatest?
Well, that would be x minus 1.
The third greatest would
be x minus 2.
x minus 3.
x minus 4, right?
These are five consecutive
integers where x is the
largest, right?
If x was 150, x minus 4 would
be-- these numbers would be
150, 149, 148, 147, 146
like that, right?
So these are consecutive
integers, x is the largest.
And they're telling us
that the sum is 185.
So the sum is equal to 185.
So what is this sum?
How do sum these up?
So we have five x's, right?
So get 5x.
And then what's minus 1, minus
2, minus 3, minus 4?
So 1 plus 2 is 3, 3 plus 3 is--
this is where I always
mess up-- 3 plus 3 6, 6
plus 4 is 10, right?
So you get 5x minus 10
is equal to 185.
Add 10 to both sides.
5x is equal to 195.
And you could eyeball this, you
could say well, how many
times does 5 go into 200, and
it's going to be 1 less than
that, right?
Five goes into 200, what, if
it goes into it 40 times,
it'll be 39 or you can divide.
If you didn't want to do it that
way, you could say 5 goes
into 195, 3 times 5 is 15.
45, 39.
So that's our answer, x is 39.
It's the largest of the
consecutive numbers.
So those numbers are
39, 38, 37, 36, 35.
Those are our five consecutive
numbers.
Next problem.
Problem 13.
A salesman's monthly gross pay
consists of $1,200 plus 20
percent of the dollar
amount of the sales.
So plus 20 percent
of the sales, s
I'll say is for sales.
If his gross pay for one month
was $2,500, what was the
dollar amount of the sales
for that month?
Well when I read it, I
essentially set up this
equation, right?
His compensation is $1,200 plus
20 percent of the sales.
And we know that that equals
$2,500 in this month.
So let's subtract $1,200
from both sides.
So you get 0.2s is equal
to $1,300, right?
And so s is equal to $1,300
divided by 0.2.
And the way I like to think
about this, 0.2, instead of
having to do this decimal, which
you could do, is I could
have rewritten this.
20 percent is the same
thing as 1/5, right?
So it's also 1/5 s is
equal to $1,300.
And now this is easy.
Multiply both sides by 5, you
get s is equal to $1,300 times
5, which equals what?
Thirteen times 5 is 65,
and add the two 0's.
So s is equal to $6,500.
So that's the monthly
sales that month.
I was a little redundant with
the word "monthly" just now.
Next problem.
Problem 14.
OK, so they've drawn a circle.
And then, let's see, they've
told us that
this is, let's see.
They tell us that this
is 40 degrees.
Let's see, Naomi makes
silver jewelry.
For one style of earring, she
cuts wedges from a silver
disk, which I guess is depicted
here, as shown in the
figure above.
Each wedge makes a 40-degree
angle at the
center of the disk.
If the weight of each uncut
disk is a uniformly
distributed 2.5 grams-- that's
how much this whole silver
disk-- I should've done it in
grey instead of magenta
because it's silver, but
anyway-- how many grams does
each wedge weigh?
So we essentially just have to
figure out what fraction of
the entire circle
is each wedge?
Well, each wedge
is 40 degrees.
How many degrees are in
the entire circle?
Hopefully it's second nature to
you right now, but there's
360 degrees in an entire
circle, right?
So the wedge is what fraction
of the entire circle?
Each wedge is 40 over 360
of the entire circle.
And that's what?
That's equal to 1/9.
Divide the top and the
bottom by 40, right?
Four goes into 36,
right, 9 times.
So each wedge is 1/9 of the
entire circle, and I just did
that based on the fact
that it's 40
degrees over 360 degrees.
So if each wedge is 1/9 of the
entire silver piece and the
silver piece weights 2.5 grams,
then each wedge will
weigh 1/9 times 2.5
grams, right?
And if we want to write 2.5 as a
fraction, how do we do that?
That might be convenient
right now.
Well, I'll tell you, that's
the same thing.
And you could multiply it out,
and that's all fine, but you
could also recognize that 2.5
can also be written as 9/4.
Oh no, no it can't, sorry.
2.5 can be written as 5/4.
No.
I'm pathetic.
2.5 can be written
as 10/4, right?
Because four goes into
10 two times.
Why am I even writing 10/4?
See, my brain is
malfunctioning.
2.5 can be written as
5/2, which is 10/4.
I was somehow thinking of the
number 9, and I'm not going to
make excuses for my deficits.
Anyway.
So what's 1/9 times 5/2?
It's 5/18.
So each wedge is going to
weight 5/18 of a gram.
The other option is you could
have divided 2.5 by 9 and you
would have gotten another
answer with decimals.
Either one would have
worked because these
are free answer questions.
Next problem.
Can you actually use
a calculator on
the SAT these days?
If you can, that would've
been an option as well.
Problem 15.
If x squared minus y squared is
equal to 10 and x plus y is
equal to 5, what is x minus y?
Before I even read the rest of
the question, when I saw this,
it should be like your knee-jerk
reaction when you
take the SAT.
When you see x squared minus y
squared equals 10, well that's
the same thing as x plus
y times x minus
y is equal to 10.
You just factor this difference
of squares
immediately.
You almost can do that
before you read
the rest of the question.
And they tell us what's
x plus y?
x plus y is 5.
So 5 times x minus
y is equal to 10.
Divide both sides by 5, you get
x minus y is equal to 2.
That's it.
Next problem.
So they draw us--
let me color.
So they draw us a rectangle.
And then within that rectangle
there is another rectangle.
It looks like this.
Another square, really.
And what I've drawn doesn't look
that much like a square,
but it's close enough,
I think.
You get the idea.
And this is, I see, a right
angle, right angle, right
angle, right angle.
They tell us that this
distance is 2,
this distance is 3.
In the figure above, what is the
area of the shaded square?
So this is a bit of a trick.
And actually, let me do it in
the next video so I can kind
of delve deeper into
the trick.
I'll see you in the
next video.